[Music]
this is jonathan pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Music]
[Applause]
hello friends
welcome thank you all for coming for
making time today to chat with jonathan
pedro who has himself been so gracious
as to make time to come to this
exclusive interview about his wonderful
new project god's dog
i'm very excited to talk to you jonathan
about this uh i had the pleasure of
reading the entire thing or rather
volume one
beforehand and i read it uh in one
big gulp so to speak
couldn't put it down it was fantastic
and this is even though it was on a
computer screen which i hate
um i would much rather have it you know
in paper form but still i i gulped it up
so i'm very happy to talk to you about
it and welcome to our little
zoom room inside nicholas kotar's
patreon community thanks i know i
appreciate you reaching out i'm really
happy
this is the first like discussion i'm
gonna have publicly about it so i'm
happy that this is perfect
i win
jonathan uh if you you don't need to be
introduced to these people uh they are
here to see you however
um i would like you to introduce
yourself not as jonathan pajot but as
jonathan pedro writer because this is a
new
manifestation of you as as person so
tell us a little bit about jonathan
pedro comma writer who is he who is he
um so it's funny that a long time ago i
was more of a writer so when i was a
young adult i guess starting around 1718
uh i was part of a theater group this
like big christian theater group you
know it was like like 50 people in like
massive production and musical and stuff
and so they asked me to write a play for
them
and which brought me to end up actually
writing three plays so i wrote three
plays for them
it was like it was a musical plays with
uh
math and i also directed them so i kind
of started in this weird slash theater
world so that's where i uh developed
let's say my
writing
but then i kind of gave it up for quite
a while well writing i was writing
mostly theory stuff and not writing
fiction but i always knew that i would
come back to it
and then this idea came to me um i think
it it started around the first time i
had the idea was probably in
2003
2002 2003
um and so i really wanted to write it
down but my life was so crazy and messy
and so or i i kind of
asked my brother if you would do it with
me
and that's what we did we just kind of
wrote it slowly in our spare time but uh
for me this is like an opening i want to
see how people react to this and how
they like the story and if they do then
i have a lot more storytelling that i
would like to be involved in
aha so you're presenting yourself
to the masses and if the masses turn up
their nose and say jonathan i don't want
anymore of this you're going to be like
i'm not going to read anymore i don't
believe you well it's not that i it's
just that i have so many things that i'm
doing so at the same time so it's like i
always have to decide what
is most uh what is worth my attention
you could say so people say jonathan no
the your writing is not so good and your
black project's not so good i'm like you
know what i'm doing this icon carving
thing the people seem to come i can just
do that and i'll be fine
all right fair enough fair enough
um so let's let's start talking a little
bit about about the story so there's a
lot going on uh in this in the story you
say you say that you started to have the
idea in 2002 2003 but this manifestation
of it is clearly influenced by things
that have been happening over the last
year or two um and there's a lot a lot
to unpack um you think so but no this is
really what we wrote and we finished
writing 10 years ago
because we knew it's also because we
knew what was
coming in terms of of just uh world view
and everything and so the fact that
giants are now back on the menu let's
say since
this is just complete insane coincidence
but we wrote
what's there is what we wrote as a
screenplay you know 10 years ago yeah
wow because it it reads like an episode
of uh of uh
yes
yeah it does it's
one of the reasons why i was so excited
about lord of spirits and so excited
about father stephen's work uh it was
because i was this is the stuff that
i've been thinking about in terms of
story form this is what i wanted to
plunge into but i was always nervous to
talk about some of the traditions
because of how the book of enoch is was
kind of suspicious but i just feel like
father stephen has solved the book of
enoch problem for everybody like now
there's nothing weird about talking to
talking about it like there's no there's
no strangeness about the whole coupling
of angels and and man it's just oh no
it's just a ritual you know and it's
it's like without it no big deal it's
the big deal
it doesn't it doesn't confound
metaphysics like it doesn't create a
strange uh rupture between you know the
tradition where we understand the
relationship between the invisible and
the visible let's say
okay so the the central conceit of
everything is the garments of skin right
so for those who may not have listened
as much to your podcast as they should
um would you uh would you please expound
on the idea what what are the garments
of skin where do they come from what's
the deal
so the the i discovered kind of the idea
of the garments of skin was when i read
saint gregor of nissa
and saint gregory nisa talks about the
garments of skin that's something that
you need to kind of get rid of you know
these garments that are given to adam
and eve really
being our biological bodies in a way
like the body of death you could say and
so it includes the idea of the body of
death but then it also includes pretty
much everything that is added to the
body in order to protect you
um and so this is uh paneotis nellis in
his book
uh deification in christ really goes
into this in a really interesting way
where he talks about
all of civilization basically being
versions of these garments of skin
and so it's basically just anything
added to human nature so it includes all
technology
all um
you know all medicine all weapons all of
this is included in the concept of the
garments of skin but then in the story
form what it ends up being is something
like the first relic
that ever existed that is the first
thing that was made so god
makes these garments for adam and eve
gives them to them and so now this this
outer covering becomes the first object
of in the history of humanity and so it
has a kind of power
that
is the power of the border you could say
the power the power of deciding what's
on the inside and what's on the outside
and so that's that's the conceit of the
story this this garment has a kind of
power to define inside and outside and
so it gets transmitted from generation
to generation
so the
this may sound this may seem like a like
a simple question or maybe not a not a
sufficiently
well thought out one but i think
i'm going to ask it for the people who
are going to be embarrassed too are the
garments of skin good or bad
that's right they're both that's the
whole idea of the garments of skin is
that they are ambiguous and every time
they bring something positive there's
something negative in the outset and
every time they bring something negative
there's a way to turn it into positive
and so that's really the
the notion of the of technology or any
human action really is something that's
something like that it's a it's an outer
action and so it has a death to it
because it's it's kind of crystallized
and it's outside you but then so it can
become an idol or it can become a tool
and and it just depends on how it's used
and so that's why the garments in the
story will move
you move between the sides like go to
the bad side go to the good side and
people are fighting to keep the garments
on their side let's say to be able to
have the power to define the limit
so then uh how would you answer somebody
who says why are you calling it a relic
then
if relics are supposed to not simply be
bearers of power and this is not an this
is not a trivial question because the
question of grace versus power is
something that's very strong in
contemporary storytelling and i'm sure
you've noticed this you've talked about
this a lot uh any sort of world that's
built in a fantasy setting that involves
divine powers
most of the time
is uh expressed by writers who are not
christian as
um as a fairly pagan outlook a very
pagan world view of humanity trying to
either placate angry deities or kill
them
in in any way shape or form and the the
traditional uh christian worldview then
would look at relics and other objects
of power so to speak uh to put it
crudely not as manifestations of power
for humanity to grab and then use for
their benefit but rather uh artifacts of
grace that can help one enter into a
deeper reality so how does that work
within the world of the story then
well it actually tries to encompass both
of what you said at the same time and so
the idea is that the garments of skin
are
of grace that is we always we have to
remember that god gave the garments of
skin to adam as a gift they're not
they're not part of the curse they're
actually a way to
to circumvent the curse yeah but in that
but it's also a kind of uh roundabout
right it's like god is giving adam and
eve a roundabout to ultimately come back
to the same place but that roundabout
has certain consequences
and those consequences are basically
uh you know the
the lineage of cain and the lineage of
civilization which god is constantly
covering constantly transforming so
that's i think that's the way to
understand it is really that god
whatever action we pose even if it's
fallen or if it's
evil god can cover it and bring it back
into glory so in a way it actually so
the garments of skin ends up being both
at the same time they end up being
something like an evil power that can
kind of act on the world and impose
itself but then there's a way in which
god can cover that and then make it
participate in a
more
a more unif a real unity you could say
so
because none of that is going to be
explored theoretically in this story
it's just going to be a story about
about the relic will will manifest
itself in the narrative form like not in
a theoretical form right you're not
you're not writing propaganda you're
writing a story yeah there are very
little few explanations in this story
they just it's just the story
you just ditch his deal you just deal
with it just deal the story
so tell me um is this a historical story
is it a fantastical story what is it
and this is also the same problem is
that in a way we're trying to bridge
we're trying to create something which
is going to encompass both at the same
time so it is definite so in a way you
treat certain
uh
let's say biblical aspects or kind of
traditional aspects as very take them
very seriously
and then on the other hand there's a
very loose
capacity we have to dive into the story
and for example like there are certain
characters which exist together which
obviously are completely anachronistic
like you saint george and saint simi in
the style light did not exist at the
same time
we all put them in the story kind of to
to create something which
in which the same becomes like a type
and becomes like a character and
hopefully we i know it's tricky and i
and i know some people are going to get
angry at this like for sure but we hope
that ultimately what's going to come out
of it is going to be something like a
surprise
um
like if i tell you the impetus of what
made us want to do made me want to do
this you can maybe understand what it is
i'm trying to do
when when i started thinking about this
this was right at the time when there
were all these stories and movies coming
out which were using christian imagery
and christian mythology to destroy it
right it was at the time of that movie i
remember i don't know
yeah stigmata constantine then a little
later dan brown and da vinci code it was
like we had a slew of these uh stories
and images which were using the
christian mythology to to basically
destroy there was also um
there was also
neil gaiman's season of miss which was
earlier but there was something in that
where he was using lucifer as a
character and his hierarchy of heaven
and earth but ultimately to really
destroy the christian uh the christian
worldview um and so my conceit at first
when i thought of the story i had this
idea of like saint jordan saint
christopher like a buddy story of two
like warrior saints you know fighting
monsters and i i just saw it like i was
like they could do like i thought of a
really subversive hollywood type
coming up with this idea and i and i
thought it would be such a great idea
for a subversive hollywood type and then
it kept playing on me and i thought what
if i did the opposite what if i put up a
story that people think looks completely
subversive yeah but that ultimately it's
actually going to turn back towards a a
truly kind of christian world view and
so that's why there's going to be some
trickiness to some of the elements that
as people encounter it but
hopefully they can trust enough to know
that we're going towards a
place
well it it requires a kind of
a historically accurate
uh engagement with a geography that
we've lost
right um
geography is history and it is not
history it's both right and they
you're not it's not supposed to exist in
some in two completely different and
completely uh distinct spheres you're
supposed to be comfortable with going in
and out of it and even though the
medieval mindset certainly would not
have
accepted a fantasy story they would have
considered it to be a falsehood and
considered it to be sinful still you
have legends that were written during
that time that are clearly historical
and some of which are not even
idiographical but they exist in this
uneasy kind of tension with with the
existing canon and also with the larger
canon of scripture and and the writings
of the holy fathers it's it's really
it's strange
it would be strange to a traditional
christian from long ago to think about
the gradations of truth that we talk
about all the time like scriptures are
the most true and then geography is a
little less true the writings of the
father they're they're
most of the time are pretty true and
then you have the legends those are like
they're not true at all you should just
no i mean they would they would never
relate to it that way so you're trying
to kind of push people back into that
kind of way of seeing the world yeah and
the story of saint christopher is the
perfect place to push back into that
because it has so much of that problem
inside it like the problem of dog-headed
men the problem of legends which appear
in the 12th century the problem all
these problems but that when you when
you were able to kind of pull back a
little bit and look at the story the the
big story of saint christopher you
realize that in a certain manner it's
addressing the very question
right the the it's addressing this
border place like this place in between
and so this is this is what our story is
about the whole the whole way through
even in its form like not just in its
content but in the manner in which it's
structured and the elements which are
put inside of it
yeah and so the discomfort that the the
extremely right people are going to have
is actually something they should
probably lean into because it uh
it breaks that comforting sense that we
know everything already so we don't need
to learn anymore because everything's
already clear we've already been told
everything that we need to know which is
death yeah exactly yeah it's death
exactly
but but we're hoping that it'll be like
my big hope is that if this is mostly
get people excited about
christian legends and realize how much
fodder it is for storytelling uh and not
just for those that want to destroy us
like the you know those that want to
destroy us have been diving into this
all these legends and using them now why
can't we and use them in a way that is
uh that is more
celebrate celebratory you could say
yeah and that of course
again and again this we're talking about
the the medium of the story as opposed
to the medium of
straight up telling or or
scripture or
uh sermonizing that this this form
of transmission of truth is one that for
whatever reason we've abandoned uh by
and large as a christian culture
or that we've embraced in very limiting
uh fashion so
there the discomfort is not it's a
historically contingent reality it's not
something that uh christians would have
necessarily subscribed to in ages past
um
so let's talk about the giants uh what
is it
what is it about the giants that people
keep coming back to why why has there
been a resurgence in interest
i want to present you a new series of
graphic novels called god's dog
god's dog is a very loose and epic
exploration of the legend of the
dog-headed warrior saint christopher one
of the most surprising and peculiar
traditions of the ancient medieval world
it was written as a screenplay by myself
and my brother metier over 10 years ago
and the story was taken up and even
recommended by script scouting agency it
was requested by several hollywood
studios but this story was of course too
big too strange too surprising for
hollywood
and so now
with all the control of its potential we
bring you this groundbreaking story the
full color is a series of graphic novels
the story is set in a token style
mythical version of the biblical world
filled with hidden codes ancient relics
angels giants dragons and populated with
fictional virgins
of mysterious monks
warrior saints
and more symbolism than you can imagine
god's dog contains all the intensity and
subtlety of our symbolic thinking the
world class layouts and artwork of court
nielsen all of this bound in a
mysterious and powerful story arc which
is available to all
from wide-eyed ten-year-olds to the most
seasoned of readers
the entire story with all its action and
complexity is already completely worked
out
and the first book
is near completion
now all we need to do is deliver it to
you
we're crowdfunding this because
it is only the first step
we've already been contacted by even
international publishers for this
but we want to knock this out of the
park so that our artists can do this
full time and deliver the oncoming books
at a regular and steady pace
under our control
i myself will personally not be taking
any profit from this first book but
rather i want to use this to build what
we need to tell this full epic with all
its cosmic proportions
so along with the graphic novel we are
also producing a crowdfunding only
add-on the secrets of god's dog source
book a beautiful volume in which you
will find my original drawings for more
than 10 years ago
an exploration of the symbolism of saint
christopher
and an exclusive text by mathieu pedro
on the symbolism of the biblical samson
this is the first thing that matthew has
published since his groundbreaking book
the language of creation
so jump into the margins with us be part
of this shift in storytelling where the
end becomes the beginning and where the
monster carries the king
into a new world
what is it about the giants that people
keep coming back to why why has there
been a resurgence in interest starting
by the way with darren aronofsky right i
mean that's that's kind of where the
things started to show up in yeah
yeah when the noah movie they're so so
funny because we had this story that we
were writing and then all these stories
would pop up in a popular culture and
we'd think okay we can't tell the story
anymore it's being told you know and
there are several examples uh
and that was one when there when
darynowski put his no uh movie out i
wrote my brother and i said okay our
story's finished we can't tell anymore
but yeah you realize that's actually not
how it works it doesn't work that way it
was already completely written by the
time the noah movie came out um
you know i think that there's something
about our time that you know we feel
like the like the clock is winding down
let's say in a cert to a certain respect
and there are many elements which are
popping up in culture you know the
obsession with hybrids the obsession
with
um
the obsession
with also it's kind of fall into
passions and has fallen to degeneracy
and you know all these kind of wild
desires that are let loose on the world
there's that and then there's also this
sense of a growing power right of a
state power and a corporate power which
is becoming so powerful that all of a
sudden you you realize that you can't
there's nothing to do
in the shadow of this power
and so that i think is that is let's say
what's going on in the world
mythologically is bringing back the
image of these giants but not just the
giants right also the hybrids and the
monsters on the edge of the world in
general but of course in christian terms
in biblical terms those monsters that
are on the edge they are the the giants
but
a lot of the images we see are all about
these monsters on the edge of the world
like even wonder woman as the you know
and and uh the um the amazons like all
this imagery of amazonian women is very
strong right now
and so there's many many images of this
of this going on i think that the giants
are like the the christian one and it's
actually probably gonna start to focus
towards giants
as this moves forward let's say i think
that even in popular culture there will
be more about giants
so there will be more depictions of
15-foot tall
hybridized uh human animal minotaur kind
of things as being the main main thrust
of of evil
or maybe not of evil like for us we'll
on our side yes but maybe not of evil
rather maybe other than like other
things
yeah of enlightenment of uh of of uh
something which is frightful but it
which is inevitable there's going to be
that type of uh of imagery
i think so yeah that's real that's a
really interesting thought um
yeah i'll i'll be interested to see how
how that comes out and whether or not
the sort of rising tide of storytellers
amongst the christians will be able to
in some way put that in the proper
context and avoid it avoid popular
culture being able to take those images
and use them for their own means which
is something that i hope will happen i
hope that this that this is the
continuation if not a beginning of a
kind of movement
um
of more proper storytelling a more
old
kind of rooted storytelling that didn't
necessarily used to be
in the modern sense uh limited to the
christian i don't like to say that but
that's how the world views it right this
used to be just the way people thought
right
and so i i would i would hope that that
there's enough of a burgeoning movement
that would allow
us to start telling stories like this on
a larger scale i certainly hope that's
what's going to happen with this because
uh this is not necessarily intended only
for christian audience is it
no not at all like there is there
definitely be unapologetically christian
elements in it but there won't be much
of the type of
uh moralizing or evangelizing or telling
the story of of salvation or whatever it
is that you usually find in kind of bad
christian art there'll be nothing of
that it's going to be a straight-up
adventure story you know with stakes and
arcs and uh giants you know it's like it
all the characters have their arcs and
all the you know it's just a story
basically and we we submitted it to a
script scouting agency
uh at the outset that's how this kind of
started we we wrote it we submitted a
script scouting agency they gave us a
few recommendations we fixed it up and
then they ended up recommending it to
the studios and the studios were
requesting the the screenplay yeah and
so it's like if if if hollywood studios
are willing to request the screenplay
obviously once they read it they're like
yeah there's no way
like at the end of it it's like a lord
of the rings so it's like oh yeah i'm
gonna have armies of giants like
fighting byzantine soldiers like okay
that's not that's not something we're
gonna put you know 200 million dollars
into uh so so if for us it was also a
proof that that the story stands on its
own like it's not just a christian story
it can totally exist in a secular world
um i want to get back to the question of
uh using sort of the traditional
storytelling forms using dramatic arcs
and things like this a little bit later
because there's i think there's an
interesting conversation to be had about
that but first i wanted to address
something um when you're talking about
the sort of emergence of of the giant
the hybrid in in the popular
consciousness um this is something that
struck me
a lot lately the um
the convergence between transhuman
transhumanist thought and christian
thought in a strange way recently and
that is that technology and the world
that's that's uh coming into being right
now web 3.0 the sort of internet of
things the the extension of the virtual
out into the real
um is something that people like kevin
kelly and and you know people at google
have been thinking about in the
philosophical way for a long time and
they see they seem to allow for the
possibility some of these some of these
people seem to allow for the possibility
that there is an emergent consciousness
coming into into all this and that
technology itself is somehow
a burgeoning consciousness that wants to
express itself
um on the other hand so this is
something that i find very interesting
the emergence of
alternate
uh consciousnesses independent of human
will
on the other side you have a
competing uh school of thought which is
popular especially amongst men amongst
christianity in that there is a cabal
behind closed doors
orchestrating this emergence
do you
which of those two sides do you find to
be more compelling um i will put my
cards on table i think the idea that uh
c.s lewis
shows dramatically in that hideous
strength which is exactly this the
demonic taking advantage of the
emergence of technology in ways that the
creators did not anticipate i think
that's a far more interesting and
compelling uh vision of the world as
opposed to the cabal that's hiding
behind closed doors and orchestrating
everything from above but what about you
yeah well
i think you could say yeah there's a
cabal behind there's a demonic cabal
like say it that way but there are
demons that are and so
the way that these things work is that
everybody just works for their own
advantages everybody has their own
stakes and
the stakes
those stakes don't necessarily have to
do with the with the demonic you know
taking a body in the world and
manifesting a god in reality yeah but
but they they fall in line because all
of those stakes are related to their
passions related to greed related to
power related to
uh you know to having power over others
and so it doesn't have to lay itself out
as this super structured thing of people
sitting in dark rooms like you said uh
you know but nonetheless
it it manifests itself through our
passions and through everybody's desire
to to get what they want and so but it
so it is organized but it's not
organized in the way that we would think
it's organized through everybody's own
interests
but i think it's definitely something
which is
it's so it's so it's it's so interesting
and disturbing and scary to feel like
you know we're sitting in the book of
enoch basically and we're kind of
watching it happen and we're actually
watching the birth of a new god or a new
religion
um
and everybody seems to think that that's
like so many people seem to think that
that's plausible even people that are
secular that are yeah
so it's a very scary and it's very scary
and disturbing that's for sure
yeah certainly i mean
yeah neither one of those two
possibilities is one that's particularly
exciting exactly
um let's talk a little bit about this
entertainment for the wider world right
entertainment that's inspired by the
christian vision that we hope is going
to be something that doesn't merely
entertain that doesn't merely
uh provide for an escape constellation
although those those things are
important but also might provide a kind
of uh door or window into
uh individuals being able to experience
reality at a deeper level at a more
transcendent level recently there have
been conversations or rather let's let's
step back step back a bit what would be
your answer to the ever-present question
that i encounter all the time
as orthodox people we shouldn't be
wasting time writing fiction because
fiction is a waste of time it's not it's
taking it's taking you away from the
things you should be doing which is the
ever
uh ever spiraling upward uh ascent in
the spiritual life how can this possibly
be something that you need
what would be your answer to that
well my answer would be that for whoever
person said that
um you could say something like this
this is not for you
like i think it's wonderful that you
that you have like that you spend all
your attention praying and reading the
lives of the saints like that's awesome
it's actually wonderful and i would say
like you know thank god that there are
still people like that in in the world
they're way too nice man that's not what
i would say
but but i think that you know if you say
that just to someone like if i say that
to you and then i go home and i stream
netflix yeah we have a problem right we
have a we have a problem and so i would
say that it's it's to really understand
it in terms of a ladder and in terms of
the lower rungs of the ladder and i
think that it's true that in a way
fiction does not at all play the same
role that liturgy that
sacred music that the lives of the
saints that icons play not at all they
are quite
they're much lower on the ladder there's
something akin to the type of
of fairy tales that people would hear in
in their villages you know the type of
epic poetry that you know that still
existed until not that long ago you know
bard would go around and sing these
songs you know these have always existed
the idea that this is that
fictional stories and stories that are a
little more
that tug a little more at your passions
you could say the idea that those didn't
exist before and that this is a modern
thing is completely false the problem is
that
is that things are lopsided and that
we're obsessed with uh entertainment and
that entertainment has replaced uh
religion has replaced
the things that ask most of our
attention um so
i would say we need to if we want to
help people come back we need to put
things on the lower bars of the ladder
so that people can see them and people
can start to kind of climb back into a
participative world
that's my best answer to that that's i
mean that's a great answer and i think
something implicit in that is the is the
acceptance and the humility that many of
us don't have to recognize that we can't
that we really can't jump over those
lower rungs and immediately go up to the
higher and to the higher ones to get the
full appreciation of what iconography of
what uh of what the depth of the poetic
language of the hymnography is trying to
tell us until we have a substratum of
figurative
syntax with which to be able to populate
those realities um john simmons yes you
are mentioning st basil already dealt
with this in his in his oration to young
men uh we could talk about that um but
it's uh
it's it's important it's important for
not merely for those outside of the uh
of the church but those within it
because
primarily because of this very
uncomfortable reality that some people
don't want to think about and that is
that our hearts are very cold
and they're not getting much warmer and
the and the reality of death as it's
come at us in covid has not tended by
and large to soften our hearts it's
tended to make them harder and it's
tended to make the division stronger
which suggests to me that we need more
not less of the kind of heart softening
things that stories give us
because without a softened heart you
could you could enter into a spiritual
experience absolutely and then you will
be one with the demons because they will
delude you very very quickly because
your heart is incapable of accepting the
softness of grace
and there there is an experience an
intense experience of oneness with other
that happens when you encounter any
story when you're reading when you're
when you're watching
and that
association of self with with other that
empathic relationship
is something by the way that we really
don't have right now because we've been
physically separated from other people
and zoom doesn't provide it so for a lot
of people the only thing they have is
story
and i'll tell you that you know the
thing that i get emailed about the most
of all the things that i do
isn't my novels
it's not my more kind of theologically
oriented stuff it's the fairy tales that
i tell or for ancient faith those are
the things that tend to
tend to
resonate with people the most the simple
eternal fairy tales so um so i think
yes i think this fits within that within
that larger
genre in a very in a very interesting
way without you know it still pushes
some boundaries which is important as
well because any kind of creativity
can't simply sit in the background and
just and just be passive you have to you
have to push people on towards something
else and like i said from the beginning
the the story itself this this story
itself is a garment of skin and we are
very much aware that that's what it is
and it's not like we understand of the
meta question of what the story is and
so there is that's why it is going to be
there is a suspicious aspect to it i
don't know how else to say it like not
in a bad way
in the sense that there's a way in which
uh
it had for it to reach out into the
world
it has to have certain characteristics
and if we're aware of them we we we can
try to turn them more toward the inside
but i was like i was really excited that
uh greg hurwitz who is the he was like
that's incredible incredible so he he
read it and he was like yeah great and
he like he like gave us a blurb and so
it's like he's not at all a christian
you know he's not in in any way so this
is this is to me that gave me hope it's
like okay this is what we're trying to
do is is happening you know so
i just hope people christians will get
on board like won't you won't get
actually annoyed that that that the
other side is also thinking that it's an
okay story yeah because sometimes we get
very comfortable in in being separate
separate from everybody it's much safer
to be to be behind the
uh the cloister walls
back to this larger question of of the
importance of
dramatic entertainment
i don't know if you saw this but there
was a there was a rather involved
conversation on facebook a while back or
maybe about half a year ago where we're
a
rather famous orthodox personality i
won't say who this person is i don't
want to embarrass anybody but many of
you may have seen this conversation on
facebook so you may know who i'm talking
about
uh suggested that this this
reinvigoration of the need for
re-enchanting the cosmos
is something that is overblown and is
tends towards the passions rather than
towards edification this person
especially made the point that
what ends up happening with these uh
entertaining stories that are written
according to the traditional arcs that
tug at
the emotional heart strings first and
foremost not the spiritual ones
tend to produce a
an internal uh void of the kind that
needs filling constantly so what ends up
happening after you finish an exciting
and dramatic story you want the sequel
right
so
this she and so she uh this person then
um
insisted that it would be better not to
write stories of that kind but rather to
focus on more human quiet non-fiction
stories of encounter between the divine
and the human
kind of
a very different kind of story
if this person was sitting here with us
right now what
what would your addition to this
conversation be
i mean my my addition to the
conversation would be that
the stories we have from antiquity the
ones that were preserved and the ones
that were kept by christians and retold
as a way to train the mind as to train
people in understanding story arcs and
story structures were very much of the
kind uh maybe that she decries uh
including all medieval legends arthurian
legend um you know the alexander romance
there's so many there's so many to name
they don't of course have exactly the
same structure as ours because there has
been changes but in terms of creating
these
these kind of cosmic stakes and the the
these arcs of character they're all
there in those ancient myths as well and
also the fatal flaws and all of these
types of structures are all there so
i i don't i don't think i agree
i don't have a problem with the other
the other part i think it's fine to have
stories of encounters stories of people
having spiritual experiences i think
that those are useful as well but what
we're trying to do is is a little more
than that we're all we're trying also to
poke through the
poke through the bland materialism that
has taken over culture you know since
growing since the enlightenment we're
trying to help people see the cosmic
structure again and so when you when you
listen to lord of spirits podcast you
get that that's what they're trying to
do they're trying to say this is all
there in scripture this whole
cosmic aspect this hierarchy of angels
of of all these these uh these these
demons and these angels fighting and
these monsters and the below and the
abyss and all of this is this is what
this story is about we've just taped
over it like we've tried to eliminate it
and now because of that people are in
love with star wars and in love with
harry potter and love with all this
other stuff so can't we poke through
and help people see once again that this
is our story like this is this is the
the biblical story the christian story
in which we live and it's there's a
testimony to that not only
in the biblical stories not only in the
hagiography but the iconography the you
know all these these icons that if you
take the time
to look at some of these icons you
realize that that's the world that
they're in you know when you see the
eagles above and
uh all of this is something that i i we
are hoping to kind of reinvigorate so i
i don't agree i definitely don't agree
yeah i i mean i'm i'm with you for
obvious reasons but it's the the one
thing that that that kind of
argumentation tends to miss um is that
there's a garment of skin to be poked
through is that most people
have such a thick garment of skin so to
speak when it comes to realistic stories
even if they're non-fiction of human
encounters with the divine that there is
a huge
activation energy that needs to be
overcome before they're willing to even
accept this as plausible in what in
their version of flat reality
and ironically by
framing it in a more mythological and
therefore more real they don't know this
but we do in a more mythological
fantastic however you want to call it uh
setting you're allowing for the garments
of skin to be to be stretched so thin
that they're much more it's much more
easy to poke through them and allow for
the glimmerings of that reality to come
to come in and then maybe afterwards
they can be inspired by those stories
because i mean how many flat flat
materialists are are going to sit
through a story of a conversion
hardly anybody
no you're right exactly right and
and i think that it's also for me it's
also that you know for years now i've
been talking about this like i'm trying
to explain it explain it explain and
explain it but it seems like i also have
to
and i complain and i also complain about
the quality of the story and so i also
kind of have to make my own to prove to
people that i take this seriously that i
am also wanting to kind of
uh be involved and to try to tell a
better story so this is this definitely
part of it as well like why we're trying
to get this done well and and it's it's
putting your money where your mouth is
right and it's making it's there's a bit
of vulnerability that needs to be uh
exposed here because you know all
stories are subject to the criticism of
the masses that's right as soon as it's
out there it's like
this and that you know whatever i don't
like this i don't like this somebody
there'll be a bunch of other you know
youtubers are going to be starting to
start complaining about your stories now
right that's right exactly
um so then
what do you think do you think there's
there's a way that we can limit that
that knee-jerk reaction
fill me with more drama fill me with
more drama what is there some way that
we can is there something that we can do
with our stories that can
limit that kind of reaction that we that
we wouldn't want to see in our readers
well i think at least like in my case
what i'm hoping to do with this is to
point people back to
the traditions surprise people and say
you know oh these what are these
traditions talking about like what do
you know is there really a saint
mercurius is there really a saint george
and what what's his story uh and and uh
is it as wild as the one you're telling
maybe not the same but it's pretty much
as wild as the stories that i'm telling
and so
trying to get people back into that like
one of the things that's going to happen
you know as you've seen that the people
who were watching this uh your patrons
have seen
in the preview that i've said we kind of
set up this mythological old testament
narrative but that's going to come back
so like all through the the story you'll
see all the old especially in genesis
all the old testament characters kind of
reappear as
feeding into this mythological story and
that's what we wanted too is for people
to to get excited about these characters
and go back and rediscover them in their
original context
so what's the what's the plan for the
series then this is volume one how many
volumes do you anticipate there being
well
we'll see that so this was a screenplay
right so we we actually when we wrote it
at first it was about three times the
length of a screenplay because we didn't
know what we were doing obviously
and then when we finally whittled it
down to the length of the screenplay
there's so much that we had to cut out
which is good because it gave us really
a very purified way of telling the story
and when you read even the first volume
you'll feel that it's it's very
streamlined and very kind of purified in
terms of the the
the narrative so that was great but
there's all this other stuff and so the
the decision the question i'm asking is
if this is successful enough like if
people really like it people really get
involved in it one of the things i'm
hoping to do is to reintegrate some of
these streams that were clipped so to
make it even more epic like a lot of the
streams that are clipped were things
that would make it even more into like a
multi-arc uh epic story so so it really
depends on how people like it and how
people are willing to kind of get
involved because the idea with this is
you know the artist that that is working
on the book we've been working on this
for like three years wow uh but it's
mostly because he's been doing it very
much
part-time and he has young kids
and he has some health issues in his
family so all this has kind of limited
him so what what i'm hoping with this
book is that we raise enough money so
that he can quit his job and just do
this full-time if that happens then i'm
really hoping we can start putting books
out you know like every six months or
every eight months or whatever uh and
then
if and if that works then we could make
this bigger you know and add a little
multiverse
like a poultry verse version of god's
dog
hey that's that's in the ether right now
everybody's talking about multiverses
that's right yeah well
multi-cosmoses
um all right so
uh tell us about the practical uh things
how is this coming out uh how do you
want people to act
all right so the the
it starts on october 31st we're starting
on halloween the crowdfunding and if
you've read the if you've read well
actually no the people that won't you've
read it you'll see you can see why like
the first the first scenes of the story
happened at uh during carnival um and
that's when the monster appears and so
it's just a it was just perfect to start
it on halloween um and so it starts on
halloween for two months
and people can go to on indiegogo and
there'll be different ways to support it
obviously buying the book
um and then i'm also selling prints and
signed prints for people who want to
kind of be more involved and give more
um if we reach a certain amount like i
think it's 50 000 then we're going to
add another
another book which is going to be called
the secrets of god's dog which will have
some articles about saint christopher
that i've some that i've written some
that i will write and a text by my
brother he hasn't published anything
since his book so it's great attacks on
samson and the relationship between
samson and the cherub and the flaming
sword which i think people get excited
about that cool um and then some of my
art that i drew at the uh ten years ago
that people haven't seen so like with
this extra book and then people can buy
pages from the book as well
so that's the like original pages so
that'd be like the tried to get people
who want to kind of support it at higher
levels will have things that they can
that they can get to and then ultimately
we're hoping to put out a pdf of it as
we reach also a certain level then
people can can they be like ten dollars
people can buy the pdf as well so those
will be like the major
uh the major ways that people can
support it
well and the good thing about indiegogo
is that whatever you make you make
it's not an all or nothing kind of
platform so um
everybody who's listening and who are
going to be listening to the recording
of this later
you needn't worry about this reaching a
certain threshold
which is the the one problem with
kickstarter is that if you don't make it
up to a certain level the whole thing
kind of collapses so
um that's that's a good thing whatever
you whatever we are managed to to
scrounge up uh for uh for this project
it's gonna be there but um what i like
about about the whole um crowdfunding
thing is that uh it's a it's a way of
gathering a tribe together a a community
so this is in some ways it's it's a pure
form of contributing to the written word
than buying stuff at amazon
you're immediately it's it's a you know
it's an unmediated experience in helping
uh craftsmen and artisans get their work
out it's more medieval isn't it yeah
definitely yeah that's how it feels we
wanted to just we also wanted to do it
ourselves to stay in control of
everything yeah because obviously once
you start getting involved with editors
you know they have their own opinions
they have the marketing team they have
all this and we feel like this story
this is the story like this is the story
we want to tell we feel like it's been
proven in terms of having it read by
enough people so
we don't want it to be changed so this
is the story we're telling that's why
that's one of the reasons why we're
doing it on our own i already had some
editors some uh publishing companies
write me
uh and ask if we'd be interested to
submit it or whatever but
this is how we're doing it well no it's
better the unfortunately the reality is
now that if you don't if you don't skew
to a certain cultural line you're not
ever going to get it published and
yeah this is the way to do it and i
honestly hope and i think that this will
happen and this is going to be the
beginning of a bunch of different
projects and as soon as this becomes
as soon as people see how it can work i
think this is going to be an avenue for
a lot of creatives to start
experimenting because it's a harsh
taskmaster if you do a bad product
nobody's going to buy it so this is a
it's a it can be a humbling thing but it
can also be a very exciting thing so i
wish you a lot of luck and a lot of
providence and i think i think it's
going to do great
thank you so much i appreciate it and
thanks for the support and and all this
it's it's great i'm happy to know that i
have like i feel like i even have people
like i have a team in a way it's not not
directly but kind of an indirect team
you know there's you in paul king's
north and there's all the and and even
rodriguez and there's people around that
are like yeah jonathan go do it and i'm
like
so i feel like i'm being i have a i have
a good good amount of people around me
that so that i'm really grateful for
that so thanks yeah absolutely
you